you think the world would be a better
place if women couldn't vote
I mean voting in itself I have questions
about the validity and the use of voting
but hey ho who do you think makes more
logical decisions men or women men
us is more leaned towards an emotional
response that may not make logical sense
females have compassion what are some
things that women are naturally good at
giving birth what are some things that
men are naturally good at not
women are naturally better at than men
living
yeah
I don't know
absolutely nothing
women are better at everything what are
some things that men are naturally
better at than women John
of the women I'm trying to what trying
on I'm not you met you mentioned that
women are more compassionate what are
some things that men are better at
decision making future planning Vision
Direction I think we don't talk enough
about Vine masculinity we talk a lot
about Divine femininity but there's
Divine masculine which is not flashy
it's just about decision making
processing logic sense you know I'm not
saying these are things that are women
can't access because everyone male or
female has their masculine feminine
energies that they access but we have a
natural leaning what are some things
that men are naturally better than women
are physical Sports because they
biologically have more testosterone do
you feel like when you're with a guy you
want to trust his decision making if I
can't make a decision I'll Trust his but
if I have my decision then 50 50. it's
always really nice to trust his decision
anyway okay okay if a woman hits a man
should she expect to get hit back yeah
yeah I think so too right if she expects
to hit him and not getting if you can
give it you can take it definitely I
think right
different like I know guy men shouldn't
hit women but if a woman hits you fast
then why shouldn't they retaliate if a
woman hits a man why should it be
treated any differently
if a woman hits a man that he is he
should be allowed to defend himself
because I feel like if
ever like fully like banging a guy in
the face like I don't know like
sometimes I feel sorry for guys like if
like there's only so much someone can
take and like some girls are strong like
I don't know like it's not acceptable
but at the same time it's like you
shouldn't I don't know I know I should
be hitting anyone like full stop agreed
it's wrong for a man to hit a woman but
if the woman is provoking him and
kicking him to the floor how else is he
going to defend himself he's going to
hit back however if a woman isn't doing
anything and it's just an abusive
relationship that is obviously wrong do
you think that if the man and the woman
are hitting each other in a relationship
that it's maybe not an abusive
relationship they're both just toxic or
they're mutually abusive to each other
they are mutually abusive to each other
like [__] that like you shouldn't no one
should be like if that is your
relationship like game over like end up
can men hit women in the name of
self-defense I don't feel like you need
to hit a woman to self-defend yourself
you could push her that's not hitting
her or run away like do you know what I
mean do you believe in equality I wish
there was equality but I don't think the
world would make sense with complete
equality I'm not here for violence
against women like I'm not trying to
what about self-defense what about
self-defense again I think as a man you
can contain yourself and you know I mean
control the situation it's kind of real
life then I've got to do what I need to
do to reset my life honestly I have to
do whatever at least you know me
whatever needs a must I mean we're gonna
do that I have a question if my producer
at their blessing goes up to Dwayne The
Rock Johnson and hits him can Dwayne The
Rock Johnson hit him back absolutely
could you hit him I'm provoked so
wouldn't you say that's a little bit of
a double standard you have then for men
and for women because I guess Mom that's
a weaker Man versus a man that's clearly
stronger an offense black woman against
women you know I mean it's too fat how
is it fair when when Dwayne The Rock
Johnson is much stronger than him and
because Dwayne Johnson put in the
[__] work I need put himself to that
size in it so if he happens has that
size not shrimp that's his business you
know what I mean but I think man against
man is always going to be fair I wonder
if someone's gonna be fair man against
woman not so far so you do think you
think Chris Brown was wrong for hitting
Rihanna even if she hit first I'm not
gonna comment on that because
what kind of question is
n't there like I don't know what
happened between them I don't know who
hit first but we're glad Breezy's back
we're glad he's back in London stages
man that's the main thing yeah it's been
a while do you think
do you think a woman
man that she should expect to get hit
back no absolutely not no a man is so
much stronger than a woman so if I
slapped a man and he hit me back he'd be
10 times stronger like the men men are
the more physical stronger gender pick
two out of the three okay looks money
and loyalty I don't need him to provide
for me I would like money so I'm just
because they're like like for my family
and stuff I bet you just said loyalty
and look now are you switching no I'm
switching it I'm looks don't matter as
long as they're loyal to me but money
supports me and my family that I bring
into them so that that means more to me
if you had to pick two of the three
looks money or loyalty what would you
pick oh loyalty and looks like like
hold on loyalty and money yeah
absolutely so like 300 pounds you could
still
yeah I mean I could steal 300 pounds
yeah you still gotta hook up with them
300 pound guy the looks are gone he's
ugly
or he could be hot and Rich but cheat
every once in a while you know nah nah I
mean yeah I don't know I don't know
let's let's let's put a picture to it
okay Adam Sandler
okay
or Chris Brown but he cheats
hell no I have no cheaters no not in my
corner I'm sorry you're you're keeping
Adam Sandler yeah loyal Adam yeah
why not do you guys leave a poor man for
a rich man no but they need to have like
um work
they're just like oh [__] no no this
isn't this isn't wait they didn't have
the money at the moment that doesn't
matter as long as we get on that's right
this isn't build a bomb right so like
he's he's poor now he's not making money
in the future are you leaving the poor
man for the rich man it's not it's not
he's gonna get money he's not he's not
gonna say it matters only for if their
personality yeah I couldn't be with
someone just because I've got money I'm
not someone that gets along
the last guy I dated was pure looks yeah
and I found that out instantly and his
looks was everything based personally
with the deadest thing on the planet and
he had money but I was like Norms you
are dead yeah it can get United things
but on a one-on-one situation no would
you leave a poor man for a rich man all
day everyday
yeah
poor man for a rich man I don't know
because my all things being equal that's
right my ex is kind of no okay maybe no
ex isn't poor same no no but it's not
about like money just doesn't like it's
not the b01 end all like if they earn
more money call if they didn't like it
is what it is like I'm not that fast
um have you ever heard of Andrew Tate
yes I have yeah are you a fan or no I
don't really care for him like that I'm
not I don't care if he's yeah I don't
care yeah no not a fan he
um after I had what he's done if it's
true he's wrong do you think if a woman
that's true what he's done do you think
it's true the thing we would ever know
we will never know the truth is you know
there's always three sides of story his
side her side and the truth we will
never know what if it is true [__] that
guy do you think that there should be a
court of public opinion like we're we're
deciding if it's true or false before
the court case has happened
you know yeah I've never heard that but
if the public could choose I think that
would be really important because
however many people they choose to be in
the court is like such a minority you
don't think like media could misconstrue
some like similar to Chris Brown and
Rihanna they didn't talk about that she
hit him too but do you not think that he
banged like do not think that he like
that she was maybe aggravating him I
love Rihanna don't get me wrong I love
her but as women we can be a bit
difficult sometimes you don't think like
there's never an excuse to hit somebody
like he was never in the like he was
never ever ever Justified to hit her did
you see how she looked do you believe in
self-defense of course so like but I'm
mad okay a man against a woman how does
that work I mean I I think if I hit a
guy I should expect to get hit back yeah
but yeah but come on now like if you if
you push if you push your boyfriend yeah
and he plays you is that right am I
pushing him if I push him I should
expect to get pushed back okay not punch
back see it's difficult it's difficult
you can't say because when I'm because
the way you're doing it I'm thinking
it's friendly right yeah
friendly leads to something different
I'm thinking like if you really try to
attack a man like I I would expect to
get attacked back do you really think
Brianna stood down was like you know
what I'm gonna take Chris Brown I'm
gonna attack Chris Brown you know
there's do you know the age difference
between them it's like what five years
but she's a big woman to him
so maybe he thought I don't know I love
Chris Brown I'm here like listen nobody
cancel me but seriously it's difficult
you don't know the ins and outs of the
situation it's difficult to judge it's
very difficult to judge you don't know
the ins and outs but nothing ever
justifies her putting her hand on him
and him putting his hand on her nothing
ever justifies that ever see I I would
disagree I would say like if I punch
someone I should expect to get punched
yeah
well to be fair
that's fair enough because if I hit
somebody fair enough they might want to
hit me back but it's about the
circumstance the circumstance always
comes into play all of that stuff always
comes into play so do you think if it's
two women right and one woman's stronger
than so so me I'm very strong I'm like
an athlete so I'm very strong so if I if
some girl hits me should I not hit back
because I'm stronger
you know what yeah if you're stronger
that's just your battle but it's
different when it's different genders
come on honestly as a man as a man why
are you throwing your hand at a female
like come on man that's all right I just
do you believe in equality yes but in
this yeah you're gonna tell me I don't
but yes I do when it comes to guys I
don't know a man should never put his
hand on a woman and okay fair enough a
woman should also not put him on so in
most domestic abuse situations it's
two-sided meaning they're both hitting
each other but in one-sided domestic
abuse where one person's hitting the
other and they're not hitting back it's
actually more likely that it's the woman
hitting the man isn't that crazy I was
surprised when I heard that too kind of
crazy yeah but I mean it makes sense
though because this one is violence is
not the answer stop hitting your
partners I agree with you just if you
love each other love each other don't
hit each other because if you hit each
other just leave each other alone do you
know who Andrew tatus yeah love them
what do you think about his arrest
I think they set them up do you guys
know who Andrew Tate is yes and I hate
him okay who who all right raise your
hand if you like Andrew Tate you like
him I think some points he makes is
valid but I feel like from what's
portrayed him on social media he's a bit
of a dick I think he's a very good
businessman he knows what to do to get
people's attention and to draw people in
and then that's how he promotes himself
and I think yeah
who are you do you think Andrew Tate is
guilty yeah no yes
um no I'd like to think so but I don't
think so you'd like to think so no just
because of how much he's in the media
phase
I don't think he's bad I don't think
he's bad why do you think as a society
we're so quick to to put a guy in jail
off of an accusation or or deem him
guilty in the court of public opinion
awesome an accusation before there's a
trial I feel like people just
um push the bad things that he says but
they disregard everything else that he's
saying but the media just focuses on
like this Snippets of the things that he
says that they know will be
controversial and will like
bring attention to him in a bad way oh
do you know who Andrew Tate is I do I do
are you a fan I am why do you think he
was arrested I think when people are
doing good in this world or are
successful and people like the well
can't work out why I'm not saying that
everything he does is right but like
they would have shut him down because
they don't know what he's up to they
don't know how he makes so much money
they don't know why he does the things
how he does the things he does
do you think that the women are victims
if they freely chose to do cam work no
do you guys know who Andrew tatus fans
oh no the name is just making me itchy
do you think he's guilty I'm not sure
there's any evidence so I don't want to
say the way because I feel like I will
be but I don't want to be biased because
I don't like him so I don't want to say
yes just because I don't like him that's
a really fair answer yeah that's a very
fair answer yeah I agree most people
should wait till the facts come out but
a lot of times in the court of public
opinion even with Chris Brown and
Rihanna it's like you never really know
what happened yeah I let everyone they
release some evidence to kind of show
that it was quite both party's fault
whereas when it first came out I was
very much Chris Brown Chris Brown you
know he's awful who do you think's
believed more as victims men or women oh
women 100 yeah I agree as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
make what we do possible